yeah it's certainly a sigh of relief for
all the agencies that were looking for
Sanders and his 13 year old son who he
took with him while on the run but now
several questions arise how a man who
was accused of violent crimes and has
had a history of run-ins with the law
was able to hide out in the very same
town he was wanted in
the surprised look on 37 year olds Ryan
Sanders's face as his nearly 10-day
Escape came to an end Wednesday night
and obviously with a case like this you
don't stop till we find him and Captain
David Baruch with the Nye County
Sheriff's Office say they exhausted all
their resources in finding Sanders for
an agency our size
obviously that is draining hundreds of
tips had come in but hours before
Sanders was found a tip LED officers to
a house believing Sanders could be
inside but he wasn't we searched that
initially and and obviously the victim's
stuff was not there and it was there
yesterday so that means he has been back
to that house at some point Sanders is
accused of kidnapping attacking and
sexually assaulting a 74 year old woman
on November 21st in what police call a
Revenge attack a family member had a
business dealings with the suspect and
that went South and so this was some
sort of Revenge for that the woman was
asleep in her home when she woke up to a
burglarized Sanders is accused of
brutally beating her with his accomplice
Richard Duncan that woman was able to
get help nearby leading to Duncan's
arrest but Sanders was nowhere to be
found and neither was a 13 year old son
but for the last 10 days officials
emphasized they still believed to
Sanders was still hiding in the Pahrump
area our criminals are not real smart
obviously
um but you figure he had zero resources
at his hand ultimately officials say a
tip late Wednesday night LED them to
Sanders hiding in a travel trailer they
say this woman Jennifer Lamar was
helping him she is now facing charges of
eating and abetting Sanders now facing a
list of charges regarding his crime
adding on to his lengthy criminal
history
after his arrest I'm told that Sanders
isn't cooperating with police at all and
Victoria you've been following us so
closely many of us wondering why no
Amber Alert was issued for the 13 year
old yeah it's been a lot of talk online
but they said that since Sanders was the
custodial guardian of his son and then
the son was also keeping in contact with
several family members while on the run
there was no indication that he was ever
in direct danger so it didn't obviously
fall under that guideline for issuing an
amber alert all right thank you very
much Victoria